dustin maze last time i was in relief
really is the bolt guy in the bullpen
game wednesday at san diego this would
be his 10th start
touring runs are fewer in all nine so
far
he's throwing the ball really really
well and he's thrown the ball well ever
since he's been a big leaguer you go
back to 2019
he continues to grow as a pitcher we're
watching
his percentages start to change between
the fastball
the two seamer which is the sinker the
cutter and the curve ball
so one away he'll face robbie grossman
here and the pitch to grossman and sit
down the left field line a long one for
pollock in the corner right down the
line
and did it hit the foul pole off the
left field foul pole by
robbie grossman and the ace take a
one-nothing lead
well you got to love that no question
you're staring down 98-99 with about a
foot and a half worth of movement
swing hard just in case frankie montas
who fans if you remember got off to a
wonderful start over his first four
starts era under
two his 10 start of the season tonight
making his first appearance since coming
off the paternity list
so seeger's got a runner in scoring
position he's 16 out of 58. with runners
in scoring position
it's a ground ball through the middle
base hitting just like that we're back
at square one
corey seeger drives home mookie belts
and it's 1-1
well they haven't hit it hard but
they've hit it in the right place and
put in between
a wild pitch with the split finger and
siege finds a hole up the middle
now the a's are looking for a two-out
hit from uh marcus simeone to break the
1-1
time oh away outside gets away from a
back to the screen
here comes murphy across the plate to
score the a second run dustin may
just yanks one two feet outside of the
left-handed batters box
no chance for will smith to get it so
the a's take advantage of the lead-off
walk and regain the lead two to one
two out single for seeger and max muncie
coming up
fly ball to center field sending canna
back
he turns it's gone
max muncie with a go ahead two-run shot
dodgers three a's two for the dodgers
home run number 101 and maybe that's
going to get max
muncie on track taylor bounced to second
in his first stat bat
first pitch swinging a high line drive
to deep left field and
gone on the first pitch of the fourth
chris taylor with a home run taylor's
eighth home run
of the year and the dodgers take a four
to two lead
zoom party in the dugout aj pollock
coming up
on this one from montas he hits a fly
ball to center field that sends canada
back to the edge of the track
sizes it up at the wall and it's gone
third home run of the night for the
dodgers as paula hits another
for pollock is 13th home run of the year
and the dodgers keep on rolling it is
now
five to two
with corey seeger that's it hard in the
ear to center field
ken is back he watches it go home run
corey seeger
no question about that one his 14th and
the fourth of the night for the dodgers
and for seeger his 14th home run of the
year
and the dodgers now lead it six to two
they're playing home run derby tonight
he's the first in second with two out
and the powerful chris davis coming up
swung on and missed strike three on a
change-up and that'll end the inning no
runs
one hit one error two left through five
and a half
six to two lead heading to the seventh
ball strike three
at the knee good sinking fastball right
there at the bottom of the strike zone
that action
joe kelly coming on missed all that time
of the injury and then
had to serve the suspension dave roberts
wanted to get him four games he said
between coming off of the suspended list
and the end of the regular season this
would be his third already and down he
goes
change up dropped by smith throws to
first to complete the strikeout and the
inning is over one two
three seventh inning stretch the dodgers
drawing closer to their eighth
consecutive
western division final they're leading
oakland six to two
the bases are loaded now bellinger
coming up
taps it gently to first olson has it and
holds on to it everybody's safe and they
lead 7-2
just stood there there was no play at
the plate
there was no play at first bellinger an
infield hit the dodgers say thank you
very much
they lead seven and now the dodgers one
out away the angels beat the padres four
to two in san diego the dodgers magic
number is one
and that's it the dodgers are division
champs for the eighth consecutive year
a dose of the familiar division champs
again the best in the west
[Applause]
unchanged